And I
want to go to Ty Cobb now,
the former Trump White House lawyer.
So, Ty, you know,
you hear what happened today
and the way Andrea described it
that Trump as
a spectator was sitting there.
No one could look at him.
He couldn't do anything.
He had to sit there all day
and listen to a lecture
on gap accounting,
all to get in front of that camera
for those few moments
when he came out and say,
well, I should be in Iowa
and now he's going to take the stand
on Monday, again, for the for the
this is now going to be again,
because he did testify last month.
It was nearly 4 hours
that he testified last time.
At one point,
he said it is a terrible, terrible thing
you've done.
You believe
this political hack back there
and that's unfortunate.
So now he goes back on
the stand on Monday.
How do you think this is going to go, Ty?
Well, first of all, Aaron, I would say
nice to be with you.
Thanks for having me on that.
I'm not sure you will testify.
I'd say it's still 5050 because
as as the lawyer in me says,
you know, why put him on?
I mean, he's going to be subject
to an eviscerating cross-examination,
which won't focus on,
you know,
what, Trump wants to talk about it.
Focus on every lie that he told,
you know,
in the ten years
that are relevant
under these financial statements.
And as we know, I mean, he told
several more whoppers
on the steps of the court today.
There's a lot of material to work with.
So I think a talented, skillful
prosecutor
could cross-examine him in a way
that would just eviscerate him.
On the other hand, that's the legal
that's the legal side.
As you all were discussing correctly,
this really isn't legal anymore
because it's clear
that his assets were inflated.
It's clear
that there are multiple
misstatements, misrepresentations
and lies on the on the numbers
that were provided.
And that's all the statute
Statute doesn't
talk about gap accounting.
The statute doesn't
talk about materiality.
The statute just says misrepresentations
and omissions,
even without a materiality standard.
So that's
that's why the judge was able
to rule in advance of trial
that Trump was Trump was guilty
of of fraud and and subject to penalties.
And this is this is really more about,
you know, the disgorgement,
the amount of money
that Trump will have will have to pay.
So there's there is nothing
that Trump said
on the courthouse steps today.
You know, that's true.
Other than, you know, I'm
I'm happy to be here
because he had a free microphone,
which you wouldn't have had in Iowa or
he wouldn't have had.
Well, and then that makes
him look like everybody else
that's running. Right.
Which he obviously doesn't want to do,
because he could have been at the debate.
He could be in Iowa there.
He purposely seems to avoid
where they are.
But when you talk about how
this all comes down to what
the amount of disgorgement will be,
how much money
Trump will have to pay, and,
of course, whether
whether he'd be able to do business again
in the way he defines it.
How significant how big do you think that
that number could be,
given what you've seen thus far?
Well, she's asked for $250 million.
I think the evidence,
you know,
the most compelling evidence on damages
so far is that was the evidence that came
in that suggested that
the Trump Organization had saved
$168 million
or received a benefit of $168 million
that would not have otherwise
been entitled to because of the
documents provided.
So I think that's I think $168
million is in evidence.
I'm not sure what additional arguments
will be made to enhance that figure.
And then, you know, the
real risk is, of course, the
the possibility
of losing the ability
to do business in New York,
which as
as we know,
the Court of appeals today said,
you know,
they were going to reserve
decision on that
until
until they consider the entire appeal,
which is which is the ordinary process.
And frankly, the way it should be done
is being treated by Trump courts
as a giant victory.
But really, it's it's
sort of the only way
the case could have proceeded.
All right, Ty, thank you.
My pleasure. Great to be with you.